hey folks welcome back to another week
of top-five scar mods of the week I'm
Cameron back he said he's no more person
this week we don't need him whatever he
served his purpose he did it if he built
us the BC and then we pushed him aside
yeah he's off drinking or something I
have a great time who cares cuz we're
back in our studio that's what matters
is what Matt and we have brought with us
the new rig said yes it's under the
table but it also comes with with new
keyboard oh I mean you had no idea with
the old one I like but also new mice
yeah yeah very important and we are
going to damage all of these and a new
break to show Skyrim looking its best
absolutely be we haven't stole bought
sab has installed so many millions of
mods okay that's a slight exaggeration
at least 30 more about 30 miles makes
the Iram look as good as we can make it
obviously one variation on how you can
make it loop we've chosen some Ian B's
and what one Ian's being not used others
but yeah there's lots of different ways
to do it but this is our way yeah so
let's take a look at Skyrim looking
super sexy welcome to solitude stare but
oh my goodness it's sunrise we're on a
boat and look at that sorry look at the
resolution on the mass is pretty good
and oh there's the Sun it is let's just
take a little look around
so Seb tell me what's going on here well
what we've done first is we've upped the
resolution of everything now that's
actually something that we never had
running by default on our old rig simply
because it just drank processing power
oh yeah it really really did so the
first thing we've done is we've
installed let me find it on our list
skyrim HD 2k textures we've got it for
dungeons the landscape the miscellaneous
stuff Rifton and towns and it you notice
it everywhere oh yeah and you know you
notice it more and more as you start
exploring around like little bits of
wood on on the ground just look at the
posts there and you see the detail of
the wood and like it's everywhere
it looks fantastic that's probably the
biggest thing that we've done and that
is it and the textures are all so
different that you might think this
looks slightly different and like with
like a solitude I don't remember the
their blades on the windmill being quite
so raked big already yeah well that's
that's another mod I've added Oh sky
red windmill big red windmill 3 haha now
this is sky falls and sky Mills distant
sorry animated distant waterfalls and
women oh yes actually we have show kids
this model for there was one time we did
it actually when you were away was mean
Daniel Dwyer oh right but also you've
what's the water mode you've included
cuz oh my goodness look at that what a
the water is good this is a realistic
water to basically it worked
extra extra well with our env which is
our usual one which is real vision we've
gone battery we've gone back to it well
I wanted to go for the realistic look in
Saren soon which is great is very
fantasy I was like no I wanna I want to
make it look more the realistic side so
it's realistic water too and it's got
another additional mod on it which is
watercolor for ENB and realistic water
too which has change the color very very
slightly and there are some other mods
that are changing the way the Sun
reflects off the water that's why I'm
really noticing I think it looks
gorgeous look it's really really
effective I like that Sam wrote the
Guardian stones we are and this always
looks great with an E and B but their
resolution on these things is grat
vastly grassley there's a lot of grass
grow
vastly improved yeah look at this my
word so you'll see the the trees are
looking a little different they're
favoring looking at thicker and Namur
lush you might describe them out I would
that's a that's what I've installed on
here exam lush trees and grass but
there's so much grass then look at
flowers yeah well I was Kevin was I
never been happier
oh yeah I know he's boys forever bathing
around in them as to frolic he liked I
was gonna say loves defraud he does
Justin go haplessly through the leaves
yeah that's his that's his like don't
I'm yeah tween the beheading when I
first installed the trees we had some
major bugs with it oh they were like all
fluffy and weird they were fluffy and
weird in the foreground and bricks in
the background so they were a mess
fortunately one of the options is to is
to basically put the vanilla style trees
back in but have them look richer and
and Russia is probably the best way to
describe its gray but not just that I
mean I've got the summer and Skyrim mod
which is what put all of this grass does
everywhere so if you were to start
wandering back towards our
lovely favorite town of rivalled we
might notice that there is this
beautiful summer fall
this'll serve thistles and look at the
resolution the Bissell scam High
Definition Gristle's it's what like
really being asked on your life except
for the overcast nurse it is just like
being me I must say like the contrast
from this is very quite really quite
high but it looks great it rewards here
once again yeah
it's amazing so I mean we've also got
the enhanced distant terrain mods on as
well so as you just just taking a stop
here I mean but this isn't the official
enhanced or distant train I've actually
got three let's just wrap things but not
is not like none of them are enhance
distance terrain
okay so different this let's go that
we've got a key tailed mountains AOF
detail mountains I'm going through my
list here HD enhanced terrain now this
is an interesting one it does this very
clever trick where it basically looks
like this grass in the distance so if
you were to just look over to your left
when it we are on a tree do you see
underneath the mountain there it does to
look like this grass yeah if you did a
knife ovd 10 on that are you gonna you
gonna ruin everything
no not necessarily it's just oh it's
just it's just a color just like it's a
it's a dappled sort of texture um but
the effect is very good yeah when you're
just close up well sorry when you're in
your regular field of view yeah it just
makes it look more detailed it's a very
clever little trick I really like that
then further on into the distance we've
got to put up but um duh buh duh buh dum
dum yeah that was more of a year
he's running here we go the Skyrim
distance overhauled beta SD o it calls
itself this was recommended on a bunch
of the graphical mods that I was
checking out earlier and loads of them
designed specifically to be compatible
so that's why I went with that one is
our main one so something you might also
notice if you look at the ropes that are
around these pillars
you know to your right in there
you see that the detail on the shape of
the ropes and everything is very very
very good as we're using another one
we've shown off before is the static
mesh improvement mod oh yes and this is
like it's just so necessary it changes
everything it takes all of the blocky
very square looking textures that are
round things that you would normally
ignore things like ropes and it and it
makes them look real you know it gives
them the shape that they honestly
deserve so we've come to vows iam
Terra's now which I will say is one of
my favorite places to Commons guys to
get ambushed to get ambushed well we've
cleared it so many times I like it
because you can see a white run in the
background there well that's part of the
distance terrain there but they are very
specific saying this acres actually
that's not normally there now think
about it you can see every part of it
that's amazing I mean look at that
that's done easy just look so good the
water mods are incredible this they
really are absolutely love them let's go
further up
oh she chases seats shall we have a
suite or we sit looking majestic it
really is he's looking so his in fact he
does look a bit different right have you
got some so I was on yeah I've got eyes
of beauty on which is what's making his
eyes look so just gold Oh grazie it eyes
have moved here his eyes they've become
good ah they've become gold recently his
eyes are actually made of prehistoric
amber tree sap inside each one is a
little mosquito a tiny containing Dino
DNA containing Kevin DNA of course well
he is part no sir he is actually yes I
remember looking at the Origin of
Species he is patient zero when it comes
ah I said have a bit of combat yeah
let's try out some nice high resolution
combat hey friends may get involved
these are the biggest snowberries I've
ever seen oh they're crazy Oh another
one oh he threw the scars I've no expert
doctor and that kills a man I said
that's some nice high-definition ice
yeah look at this and some footprints in
the snow possibly one where are you
there he is hiding behind this crate huh
oh you shouldn't have done that
no oh this is gonna end well for you
wait I love you no it didn't
the other thing now he stained my
beautiful high-resolution snow what's
good oh god let's just run away oh Jesus
bobbins all I have
are we wait for now a great idea yeah
what said that snowy trees like like
fully laden with snow yeah if it's quick
festival my very festive
Kevin van Clause would have a whale of a
time around here he would he be kicking
through the snow instead of the leaves
yeah it's true
use your family Oh fists please wait
that's gone well pop own it up BAM the
old bobbing slam yeah coming off from
time to time
oh we got ice back through the heart but
that doesn't stop Kevin van Lord
it never hasn't even though he misses
her face she done it's right his feet
are so big that just as he slams his on
the ground
yeah the impact alone shudders through
the earth so this this frost you can see
on the ground is from better dynamics no
I wasn't gonna put this one in but then
I was like I remember cam will be really
upset if I don't make this snow looking
you don't would have been very upset the
Sun is out it is out in some for it is
bright while blind yeah Kevin's not
happy about the Sun so what you're
looking at here is real ice and good it
is
it's another more that has several
options you can choose how you want it I
went with the default but there is a
dark ice option which will make things
look a little bit more real yeah this is
insane look at that bear something
that's worth noting for things like
these texture replaces is that a lot of
them will overwrite one another so I
mean just on a basic level things like
the 2k texture pack which does more or
less everything will overwrite things
like natural Gua natural grass texture
floor yeah and so you basically just
want to choose the one that you prefer
the most I mean you can really see a
huge difference in the patching on these
on these houses like it's incredible
knowledge they're like a block yeah
exactly what is underneath this I'm a
look at the resolution on an IV pretty
high resolution IV so yeah most of the
textures in here are 2 K but we do have
a couple that are all the way up at four
yeah things like the the moss on the
rocks should be full 4k and you know
obviously the more of these super high
res pictures that you install the harder
it's going to tax your system so you do
have to kind of find a happy balance yes
between something looking beautiful and
something just completely
your gaming experience server mine a
mine this is Tim Burton alright let's
have a look at some interiors with our
new Skyrim and you know what it looks
pretty great so far well odd it should
be so really atmospheric because I've
put on a very you know at extra dust
I've installed climates of Tamriel with
a fog
perhaps that's alright we're fine
Oh Kevin bad Lord might here they are I
know my punching swords are action sword
boom oh dear
oh and he's dead alright he didn't want
his ankles no no no I heard him going on
about them earlier I hate his ankles hey
he looks pretty great too textures and
the people are awesome that's a good
beard he's got yeah so all of the hair
should be much higher res and if in fact
you can find someone who won't kill you
immediately you mean I won't kill him
you can see that the faces have changed
somewhat as well these guys look a
little different to some fine hairy and
beard you got going on there sir hello
what a handsome man battleborn wholesale
cheer up wow he looks a bit dead she
does look a little sickly doesn't yeah
yeah don't take this the wrong way but
you look a little sickly a little little
Corp suffice Wow
no but nobody just said that you look a
little ravishing my holding your own
lines lady what's making this happen is
a combination of the Apache sky hair
pretty face and pretty face for men and
another one eyes a beauty of course this
is obviously not just quite worked okay
so the pretty faces man want does make a
lot of the men look like they're made
out of stone kind of yeah kiss face and
his arms are entirely different colors
yeah but look at the resolution of the
armor that he's wearing as well oh wow
yeah oh yes so this is part of the amid
iam Bourne series which is why that's
looking so tidy as well oh man this hand
has never they had one of them ah look
at the HD ness of it let's put it in the
HD water and see what happened there oh
no I hate it now come along with us
what come along well I still have my hem
thought it was better and worth his time
I see bit of a fast travel up here so we
check out the interior of reason not
burrito you have this one yeah it's a
dragon three dragons we thank you iced
assume it's my home Wow sab this looks
awesome
yeah the the mist and the dust in here
just looks really really good the fire
should look quite good as well I've just
gone and put our HDMI effects that is
that is quite a hot looking fire yeah
Oh whoopsie daisies oh no I hanged them
so I think I'll fit our Lidia's are
there more than one lady here I would
usually got a couple fighting yeah days
okay this is punch your way through this
mess
everyone's got immaculately combed here
it is so silky isn't it that's just one
touch huh a punch set a watt which mist
groove looks incredible it does all the
mist yeah not many which no really
coming over
well hello it is apparently quite breezy
here according to the tree behind you
it's amazing this looks incredible
so this is where hopefully some of my 4k
textures will be coming in oh yeah the
moss covered rocks and things like that
are all set to 4k so they should be
looking really really good
whoo on top top of that the ruins
clutter improvement which is stuff you
see around this this right here um is an
entirely separate mod of its own
okay so weird look at the water so sir
we're currently rocking about 30 between
30 and 40 frames at the moment this is
the lowest I've seen it so far down in
the in the 30s it's a lot down here
generally I've been having it there we
go it's up around the 40 45 to 48 mark
and this is with way more mods than
we've ever ever had on before oh yeah
it's the difference this new PC is made
is incredible yeah absolutely and this
isn't even with the graphics card that
we originally intended to install this
is we're currently using a GTX 780 on
our new system yeah so if we then turn
the ENB off there you can see this is
what it looks like without the MB I mean
the textures and everything are still
there it really is a lot flatter oh it's
a lot flatter I mean it it loses a lot
of the sort of contrast and punch that
makes it oh wow really
that's incredible look how much it pops
specially the skybox ROM I love it you
like your punching punching the effects
on punching in the air I turn off and on
it's pretty great like how he does his
light switches at home yeah it's like oh
it's a little dark not anymore
gosh it's this kind of feeling that I
remember getting the first time I played
Skyrim just walking around at just
propping up bridges because they would
so specifically designed to be you know
breathtaking like the incredible and you
know over time that sort of dilutes on
you a little bit I said it looks equally
awesome at nighttime as beautiful
they obviously the one of the mods we've
installed has changed the sky textures
too so we've got the kind of declares
and the Aurora's combined something it's
really quite amazing so this is actually
a combination of two mods that we're
looking at right now so the sky Roma HD
2k textures does the night sky by
default in fact it just does everything
you but on top of that we have also got
the enhanced Knight Skyrim mod and again
a lot of options that you've got on this
if you wanted to have a very colorful
galaxy sky so you can see the galaxies
up through the clouds so you can yeah
and you can change it to be like oh I
just want an aquamarine maybe I want a
purple or we can have one that's a bit
more multi-coloured a bit more like what
we've got here
well syrup here we are beautiful skyress
guy there's a dragon looking majestic on
HD very HD it sounds like you might have
an achy belly oh yeah it's just like the
classic Skyrim experience right
wandering through the wilderness our
dragon overhead I would I would struggle
to describe this as wilderness can be a
good point this feels like summer
Gardens nice gorgeous look at the
resolution roast chicken
dray chickens oh ah it won't explode
though what we must have a we must have
a clash with explosive chicken somewhere
that's not gonna stand that's not gonna
schedule
Kevin's we have to punch them all until
they explode well cept that was a sexy
Skyrim that was a very most I've ever
seen yeah it felt quite tranquil and
maybe that's just cuz we didn't blow up
a load of chickens no no no chicken
exploding this week we have a clash with
all of our beautiful more yeah every one
of everything you can't have destructive
power and good looks Sam except for high
demand or can you not Kevin banned or
dizzy exception I'm inclined to disagree
yeah I'm it's a shame they they didn't
explode but when we've taken off some of
these mods and we've reclaimed a little
bit of that processing power oh I'd love
to a bench market Oh Charlie yeah we'll
scale down some of the textures and
we're lonely well benchmark and see if
we get that 200 mark commit even 300
chicken mark I think
we could with this machine I think we
could you know what I think I'll do is I
will take the list that I've got here of
all the mods that I've installed to make
it look the way it's look today so if
you liked it you can go over to
tinyurl.com forward slash ready Sebby
blog which is usually where we've put
the vote link in I'll do a blog post
which has got all the mods that I've
used to make it look like this amazing
yes that way and also that way you guys
can tell us if there's anything that you
normally use that we haven't and maybe
just like a variation on top we've used
or a completely different mod that
missed let us know and we can keep
adding it because the idea is with this
new rig set we should be able to
continually switch around some of the
graphics boards yeah but maintain our
framerate and constantly have a
beautiful Skyrim that's what I'd like to
do because I know there are a lot of
people out there who like to push their
rig and make their Skyrim game lookers
as beautiful as boss by default but yeah
because we're testing so many other mods
that's actually something we usually
skip and so it's nice to be able to take
a look at it now if you want to like em
get in contact with us about the mods a
nice way to do that is either like reply
in the comments or you can contact me on
Twitter at Camp Fras Rob and him at
ready Sebby go absolutely you can use
our hashtag GS Skyrim I said next week
is another interesting mod showcase
right yes quite back to normal just yet
no we're doing a tutorial episode on how
to install an ENB get all of that lovely
depth of field e okay yeah - Joey you
can see there you can see the beautiful
yin B is that week the cameras whips
around Kevin standing there if you want
to know how to get those effects next
week we will run you through that
tutorial now technically we have already
recorded that every that we have we
recorded it as for this one yes we
recorded it in fact before we built this
new PC so it's made on the old one but
we are away at Gamescom in fact we're
leaving in two days
oh god I wish to do yeah we're gonna be
working hard producing some other videos
so we wanted to make sure that we didn't
leave you guys without any no great
Skyrim content to watch so make sure if
specially if you've never installed in
in an ENB before check it out because
you know what you might like it
so that'd be up now be our next week's
show and then after that we will return
to almost normality and I'll be a 5 mod
show except with that Seb
anyway so I'll be Lucy James and myself
that's in two weeks time and N and then
we promise it will be back to normal
myself and sit for it don't make
promises on c-can I'm just gonna gonna
say that so what is normal really on no
one's gonna remember anyway now you're
long in the future who knows we may all
be dead but who knows good chance yeah
good I see with Kevin around yeah well
we will return then with with questions
with the user vote with everything that
you are you expect from this show but
yeah but let us know I hope it's been
that we were enjoying these kind of
departure from normal episodes do let us
know it's always good to get feedback it
is yes
we're fantastic we'll set thanks so much
thank you first for installing all these
months we is gonna say like I did
nothing this what I would love to tell
you that it went smoothly and everything
work first time I just turned up and ran
around Skyrim and punched people that
was great bad but you did all the
legwork so I do all the heavy lifting in
life and in this game is true it's great
true
well thanks so if you're a bit of a hero
and we're back
I gotta stop complimenting you because
you never say oh [ __ ] she just like
drink it in drink in the confidence you
gotta learn how to live this life gap
well I'll try I'll get used to hopefully
alright guys well thanks so much for
watching and we will be back next week
so we'll see